slider here at South by Southwest with
everyone behind them that follow before
we get started the only reason we get to
be here covering festivals of Sundance
and Tiffany South buys expensive wanting
a huge thank you to supper suite for
hosting us blue moon El Tesoro
and all the other awesome sponsors that
let us be here covering the festival and
help you guys to promote the movie so
let me start by saying that she looks
for coming in sincerely I've seen the
film now and you guys all did such a
fantastic job and one of the things that
are really appreciated is that it is not
portraying these people that that are
super religious being like a negative
light it's just this is what we believe
you know and I'm sort of curious if you
could talk a little bit about that
aspect sure that was one of our primary
goals when we set out to tell this story
was to tell it as unbiased and as
sympathetically as possible dan and I
are not people of faith and I think that
that's why we were so deeply curious
about exploring a religious community
and people that practice you know a
really radical tradition is because we
really wanted to understand people of
faith and what that feels like the
certainty that they must have each time
they lay their heads down on their
pillow at night they know the answers
and that's not something that you know
Dan and I share so we were deeply
curious about sort of walking a mile in
their shoes yeah and you know movies are
all about empathy you know in particular
I think it was really just that that
guided so many of our creative decisions
I think it's really easy to make fun of
these folks to not take them seriously
and we really wanted to we wanted to
take their lives series seriously their
everyday lives and extraordinary stakes
that they face in practicing their
religion seriously and so while you're
following along with characters whose
choices you yourself might not make by
the film's end I think that you come to
understand why they made those
for the two you guys could you talk a
little bit about what was it about the
project and for the script that said I
want to be a part of this and if you
don't mind [ __ ] because so many
people watching this will not see me
move ahead you don't mind a little
generic but can talk a little bit about
the characters you play as well yeah my
character is Augie and you know it takes
place in a a really a very specific
religious community and it was something
that I knew very very little about and
was kind of shocked to find out how I
wasn't like a you know like what
happened in one place that happened you
know all over Appalachia and it's still
going on and you know many undisclosed
places but it was just so fascinating to
me I'm like hi I don't I wanted to know
more about these people and I think
that's why you approach any script
because you want to know more about
people in general and like he said just
having empathy for someone that you
don't agree with and you know I don't
agree with these people I mean my
character is sort of an outlier in the
community he's a non-believer and sort
of straight from the church and so he's
struggling with his relationship with
his family you know what she still feels
very close to and then his relationship
with his community which he feels not
close to anymore
and yeah well I was really drawn to Mara
and the kind of relationship she had
with her very charismatic parent and
that was something that I found really
interesting and that I can relate to and
I was also I don't know really struck by
something poetic in the reckoning that
they partaken with their faith I think
there's something that made sense to me
and my birth that gave me the shivers
about the idea of taking up a snake
being in a position of sort of surrender
that I don't understand from a religious
point of view but I do in
the in my own human way you know this is
something that thrill-seeking that we we
do all our lives and what it what is
that trying to feel trying to feel
something trying to feel alive trying to
understand who you are without without
bias is it is it even possible I think
there's something that these communities
kind of trying to get up and and I
understand that one of the things the
community to be charismatic and pull you
in that's why you know having Walton is
you know such a great actor so if you
don't mind talk a little bit about what
the reaction when you finally when he
says oh yeah I'm gonna do your moving
because you know you can pull that
performance often you don't mind sharing
yeah Walton is you know he's the
strength of our community that we set
out to build and we knew that whoever we
cast is lemuel if we didn't believe him
then we wouldn't believe this world this
story and so it was really important and
when thinking about who would embody
this complicated father this you know
charismatic preacher this very loving
man um Walton was just there was no
other choice in our minds he has such an
extraordinary empathy for the characters
he plays and he brought it pay those to
the character that maybe even wasn't on
the page and in the wrong hands um we
would have had a very different film and
and we trusted Walton to explore Lemuel
as a father and we have a special film
because of what he brought to the
character
he was a joy to work with truly you know
and I'll say I think you know when
you're a filmmaker and when you're a
writer and director in particular you
spend so much time with the script
trying to get the words right trying to
imagine how actors will one day say
these words and then when you're on set
for the very first time with an actor
and they open their mouths and they
deliver their first line of dialogue and
I remember it was something that
happened to me with truly each one of
our cast members where we're such a ball
of nerves of energy and then I remember
Waltons first scene was a very quiet
scene and just his first line was just
the most simple line and I just felt
this flood of relief yeah all throughout
my body where it's like oh we're gonna
be fine it was the same thing with
Alice's the same thing with Thomas with
Caitlin with Olivia with Jim just one by
one as soon as their first team came up
I just relaxed because I knew that we
had these extraordinary talents bringing
our story to life and and so it was just
a joy to be able to work with them and
and and since so many ways I think that
their performances bring the emotional
authenticity of our film I just say a
Walton is just one of those actors it's
really exciting to watch and be on set
with because there's some actors I mean
I think Olivia's this way where she
turns it off and on and she's pretty
casual about it and very instinctual but
Walton is the kind of actor that more
stays in that place and so when you
would walk into that church like you
were in Waltons room you know and he
made that very clear not in a way that
was you know detrimental to any of our
jobs but in a way that you know it fit
the tone of the movie and and he kind of
just set the atmosphere in the room
which really helped all the all the
extras in those scenes as well
he had just yeah this infectious quality
to him um Walton is passionate and he's
always sincere in what he's trying to
discover for the character and quite
humble in that you know he's he was
always trying to do better and I love I
think that that's what keeps performers
doing better is when they keep you know
keep
not taking it what they've got for
granted and and that was really that was
really nice Suvir around and we were
both you know really on board and
certain that these characters loved each
other and that it's the devastating
nature of how love can be true and blind
and you can actually lose the person
that you think you love when to the
feeling and it still be real yeah what
look getting back to what I said at the
very beginning one of the things that I
really appreciated was that you guys
didn't turn it into the standard trope
that that Waltons character is some evil
guy leading the evil churches these are
people that really love each other and
are supporting one another it's just a
religion or a way of life that I
personally couldn't do yeah you know I
think one of the guiding conflicts that
each of our characters in the film face
faces is what happens when your
loyalties to your family come in this
comes into conflict with your loyalty to
your faith and so none of these
characters are villains they're just
making really hard choices between two
loyalties that don't always so I'm
curious how did things change in the
editing and you do any early a
friends-and-family screening ii happened
what did it change i yes and what is the
old adage that a story is told three
times when it's written when it's
directed when it's edited and it's true
um we discovered a new midpoint to our
narrative in the editing room and it's
something that we decided to do in the
11th hour it was a very radical choice
but we had we had a really significantly
different pivot point in this in the
center of the film and in the script and
what we shot and looking at our film as
a whole even though
the sequence was really exceptional and
all of our crew camera stunts are actors
like they hit it out of the park the
scene in and of itself was too powerful
it was too jolting and when an audience
watched it we realized they could not
recover and they could not re-enter the
narrative and stay on the journey for
the rest of the film because it was so
striking and so Dan and I we're sitting
there a day before picture lock and
Dan's like Britt I'm gonna say something
crazy and he's like we need to cut the
midpoint and he goes he goes you think
I'm crazy and I sat down I took a deep
breath and I was like we do we need to
cut the midpoint and we all just sat
there with our editor Josh Lee and like
silence weighing the gravity of a
decision in such a late hour but we were
right to do that and um and it it really
transformed the film and it's something
that I don't know why we didn't see it
earlier but in reshaping the central
pivot point to the narrative and
focusing it on Mara and not Mara and
Garrett which was the old one that we
cut I it it routed us more in her
journey and it made for a more intimate
and emotional arc and I'm so happy we
did that but it was radical the strange
thing is the strange thing is when we
cut it we didn't have to touch any of
the other scenes we just sort of
clapping it was gone so we didn't have
to do any tweaking we just you know
threw in the trash bit six minutes I
like don't even think it's that
different I'm like
[Laughter]
to my I wanted everyone watching this
want to see the movie or very few people
so I don't want to reveal any stuff but
off-camera I told for the two of you
guys I'm always curious about what
memorable moments meant building is
there a day or two yeah I don't know
just the whole thing I was really
excited to work with Olivia and so
anytime I got to be on set with her and
especially the scenes where like we get
to be very like tender and close to each
other
she's just so open and such a generous
actress that made me so much better and
everything that we did together and
she's just like this crying machine
where she just decides like oh oh right
oh yes this see I'm supposed to be sad
okay and then like like just turn it on
and it's it's it's really amazing to
watch and pretty inspiring but she
doesn't take herself seriously at all
she's like so funny we're cracking up
you know you know the scenes later in
the in the film you know we're not so
nice um but we're you know we're
together right there and so shooting
those things was actually a lot of fun I
we we bonded quite a bit sweet Olivia
yeah I think the whole experience was so
fun and weird and emblazoned forever for
me on my memory and like yeah it's so
true working with Olivia was amazing I
think I'll always remember there the
snake honestly like there's a scene not
to spoil it
but I think it's Ben's if it's going to
be spoiled this means point.i handling
scene and I felt the hose so it's so
unusual cuz I guess the snake doesn't
move like anything else moves it's got
it's just pure muscle sir having that
all over you is really fascinating
experience and it's very visceral I know
I will never forget that coming in I've
been talking about myself dependi
promise there's some harmless questions
the two of you what TV show would you
love to guest star on and for the two of
you what TV show would you up the best
for making direct entourage Twilight
Zone seriously it's a tie between
killing Eve and The Handmaid's Tale
[Music]
it's Jersey Shore
[Laughter]
gosh this is so hard um my so-called
life should we all just say arrival at
the same time look alien is so
incredible the neverending story ex
machina yes like my movies I've seen uh
so true yeah yeah I mean of course like
so going the acting and alien was
incredible I think that was what just
got me so hard when I was young it's
just the that being able to really
suspend people's disbelief and the
Sigourney Weaver just like I never not
think about her think about her all the
time I actually thought about her when
we made this is something about the
isolation and the attempt to hold it
together that I really made it was in my
brain characters in cinema history
without a doubt these are anything that
you guys collect yes
I collect miniature vintage tea set
[Laughter]
[Applause]
four-year-old daughters so I can get
away with it cuz they're like her teeth
dark eBay holes and no I I'll show you a
picture they're in a little wooden house
in my daughter's room
[Laughter]
I just realized like I don't mean to I
sort of pick up little random bits of
stuff and they end up in my bag and I
wished that there wasn't so much random
little bits of whatever in my bag but
like it's not intentional well I came
out of my mom who's a film director and
then what she was doing made so much
sense to me from a young age I just
found I don't know there was something
so exciting and yeah kind of really
normal actually about when you go in a
set like it's so much just like whether
like is a little light gonna [ __ ] with
us is the rain gonna [ __ ] with us and
then it's so amazing to just see a crew
stop and be silent while you do your
weird acting and you try it it's
interesting because in life you're
always trying to be normal or good but
in film you're trying to be real you
could rebuild civilization with a film
crew like it's literally like people
there's like someone from every
profession like they're carpenters like
billers it's like a little community
it's like self-sustaining and that's
it's really beautiful it all comes
together
what was the question Oh what's like got
you into this yeah oh oh I think I've
talked about this before but the one
performance I saw when I was like young
teen was a little Paul day no a little
miss sunshine and I thought it was so
cool what he could do with a mostly
silent performance and I was just like I
want to do something like like I wanna
do something like that someday
I would say I moved around a lot as a
child I went to God I think like 18 or
19 schools by the time I graduated high
school and being the sort of perpetual
new kid I I think I became a storyteller
um you know explaining where I came from
and and why I was there I think that
started my sort of path in studying
people in worlds and contextualizing and
dramatizing
and so I think that that was always like
shaping narratives and you know
inventing sometimes was when I knew I
wanted to be a storyteller I knew I
wanted to be a writer and I sort of
discovered that I wanted to be a
filmmaker and a director a little bit
later but I always knew I wanted to be a
storyteller from a very young age I
think I have two answers one is I guess
probably boys don't cry you know which
is a queer person you know I think I saw
it when I was very young and my older
sister rented it from Blockbuster you
know two years after had already come
out and snuck into the basement and
watched it together an r-rated movie and
for me as a young person coming of age
and trying to figure out who I was just
seeing a queer person a trans person on
screen for the very first time I was
like oh wow I'm not the only one and so
that was an extraordinary experience and
then also the Lord of the Rings series
because they took me away and in a way
that no movie ever has since and being
able to transport audiences in a room
together and share that experience I
think is
the most magical thing in the world on
that nerve ACC want to say congrats on
me if I'm involved in such a great job
congrat to be part of the festival and
Sundance and all that stuff